- [Host] Bicycles are
changing peoples lives
in San Andrés Itzapa, Guatemala.
- [Mario] (speaking in foreign language)
(uplifting symphonic music)
- [Host] This is Mario.
- [Mario] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Host] And he works
here, for Maya Pedal,
an NGO that transforms old bicycles into
cheap, eco-friendly machines
powered by pedaling.
- [Mario] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Host] Marta is the
owner of one of these
machines, and earns a
living making tortillas.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- [Host] The first step
is to de-kernel the corn,
which she used to do by hand.
- [Marta] (speaking in foreign language)
(uplifing symphonic music)
- (speaking in foreign language)
(uplifting symphonic music)
(digital dinging)